PRESENTER: I'm happy to
introduce Demis Hassabis.
You probably know, or most
of you know all about him.
His bio is he was a
chess prodigy doing
a PhD in neuroscience.
Then came to MIT.
He founded DeepMind.
They developed the AlphaGo.
They developed-- before
that, Atari Games,
they developed Alpha Zero, and
then more recently AlphaFold,
and yes, in the meantime
received so many prizes,
and so on.
But anyway, that's-- you
can read all of this.
What I want to explain
is why he's coming back
to MIT every three
years or so since 2010
to give us an update about
the state of AI and DeepMind.
And the reason is
that in 2009, he
came to spend a few months as
a visiting postdoc in my lab,
and then this went
pretty well, and as you
can see from this recommendation
that I wrote up there.
And he applied to a Wellcome
Fellowship that he got,
with the idea of then
spending the next five
years working between
London and Cambridge here.
And fortunately, or
unfortunately, he
spent of these five years only
a few months with the Wellcome
Fellowship, but then
he started DeepMind.
And this was 2010, I think.
And so in 2011, we had here
actually the initial session
was exactly in this classroom.
We had a symposium that George
Tenenbaum and I organized
by the name "Brains,
Minds, and Machines."
It was for the-- one
of the five symposia
for the 150 years
of MIT, in 2011.
And it started with
a first session
in this classroom that was
titled "The Golden Age of AI".
And so you can see here
Sydney Brenner, Marvin Minsky,
Noam Chomsky, and Emilio Betsy
and Patrick Winston at the end.
And this was, by the way,
the first and only time
as far as I know that
Marvin Minsky and Noam
Chomsky were together on a
panel, which is pretty amazing.
And this was the first day.
The third day was "The
Marketplace for Intelligence".
And so there were the big
guns, like Microsoft and Google
and IBM speaking,
but there was also
startups, or other companies.
I think Colby
spoke, Colby's here,
and Amnon spoke, and Demis.
Demis looked a
bit younger, but--
And so after that, I
asked him to become
a member of the Advisory
Committee of the Center
for Brains, Minds and Machines.
Then we got with Josh
and several others
at MIT with funding
for NSF for 10 years.
It's actually 2023 is the
last year of NSF funding
for the CBMM, and Demis has
been a great advisor together
with all the great advisors in
our external advisory committee
that will meet,
actually, tomorrow
to tell us what to do next.
And so that's why
Demis is coming back.
This is a little piece of his
bio that is not usually known.
And Demis, I'm very glad
to give you the stage.
DEMIS HASSABIS: Great.
Thanks, Tommy, for that
great introduction.
I stayed over with
Tommy on Sunday evening,
and he was saying that
he found in the attic
all of these ancient
documents of DeepMind from way
back in 2010-11 that
I completely forgot
about and lost track of, but
Tommy still had somewhere.
So it was great reminiscing
about old times.
So it's always fantastic
to be back here.
It's been a few years now,
of course, with the pandemic,
but it's always wonderful
to be back at MIT
and to talk to all of you.
So today, what I'm
going to discuss
is mostly our latest
work, which is AlphaFold,
and the impact it's had there.
And hopefully, those of
you who are biologists
in the audience
have found it useful
yourselves and may be using it.
It'd be great to
hear your feedback
on that in the Q&A session.
But before I talk about
AlphaFold specifically,
and actually a lot
of the other work
that we are using AI in the
various different sciences,
I'll briefly mentioned some
of the other work we've had.
We've had a bit
of a golden year,
I would say, last year
in terms of applying AI
to all sorts of hard
problems in the sciences.
But I was going to
also just recapitulate
a few of the things that
have led up to being us
being able to do this.
It's been a kind of 10 year--
well, I guess 12 years now--
process to get to this
point, where we're finally
at the point now,
I think, where we
can apply AI very meaningfully
to scientific discovery itself,
which was always my
aim with DeepMind
from the very beginning.
So I just want to thread
the needle for you
in terms of how the different
work we've done in the past,
largely on games, then
culminated in the kind of work
that we're doing now.
So as Tommy said, we
started DeepMind in 2010
with a very audacious vision.
The plan was to effectively
build a kind of Apollo program
effort for building artificial
general intelligence,
or human level
artificial intelligence.
And back in 2010, none of
you will remember this now,
but you know I was
uninvestable, I would say,
and certainly a
kind of backwater.
And it's kind of
amazing to see what's
happened in a relatively
short space of time.
Within a decade,
really, it's gone
from that to perhaps
one of the hottest
areas of technology, science,
and also commercial investing.
So it's kind of amazing.
And it's been a privilege to
be at the vanguard of that
and be part of pushing that
transformation forward.
And in a way--
I mean, we always, of
course, plan for success,
but I think even
we've been pretty
surprised by how quickly
things have progressed
and where we've got to today.
So the mission
statement of DeepMind
was to solve intelligence
and to use it to advance
science and benefit humanity.
And we've had this in mind
from the very beginning.
This has all sorts of
implications about what
we would think about.
When we use the term solving
intelligence, what do we mean?
Well, you know, I've been
trained as a neuroscientist
and as a computer scientist.
And really, DeepMind
in the early days
was an intersection,
really, of the best
ideas of from computer
science and AI
and machine learning
and the best ideas
that we had at that time
from systems neuroscience.
And that's partly why I was
working in Tommy's group,
because obviously his group
does both of those two things.
And by solving
intelligence, what
we mean is we'd like to
fundamentally understand
the phenomena of intelligence,
and then, of course,
recreate that
artificially to create
artificial general intelligence.
And our thinking
was that if this
was done in a very general
way, then in theory,
one should be able to apply
the technologies that come out
of that, the algorithms that
come out of that process
to a whole wide range
of challenging tasks.
After all, that is what the
human brain does, obviously,
our only existence proof
of general intelligence
that we have.
And there's no, I don't
think, theoretical reason why
that should not be possible.
So the type of approach
we took at DeepMind,
which was very early, if you
think about that in 2010,
and now, of course,
is all the rage,
is a learning systems approach.
And it's turned out,
transpired, obviously,
over the last decade that
they're incredibly powerful
and they have huge
potential, these types
of learning systems.
So of course, I think
of it as two components,
really, although there are
many types of learning systems.
But of course, the one we
specialize in at DeepMind
is called deep
reinforcement learning.
So one way you can think
about this, at least the way
I think about this is
if an agent or an AI
system on the left
here finds itself
in some kind of environment
or some data stream
and it's observing,
getting observations
of that data stream.
And I think the first
job of the AI system
is to basically build a model of
that environment from that data
or that experience.
And that could be a
continually updating thing
if this is an active
learning agent.
So that's the first job of
the AI system, I would say.
Then the second job, where
we use reinforcement learning
for this, but there are
other approaches, too,
is once you have built that
model of the environment,
you can use that model to learn
how to achieve a specific goal
or maximize a reward,
usually specified
by the designers of the system,
within that environment.
Reinforcement learning does
that by a sophisticated process
of trial and error in
order to figure out
what action to take that would
best get it towards its goal.
And at least in an active
learning system or an agent
system, this is an
active learning process.
So actions are taken that
may drive a new change
in the environment,
which in itself may
drive a new observation.
So the cool thing about these
systems, deep RL systems,
is that they can discover
potentially new knowledge
from first principles
for themselves,
through this process
of trial and error.
So of course, if one
thinks about that,
then this might be incredibly
powerful in certain domains,
for example, like science.
So obviously, as all of
you will probably know,
AlphaGo was our big
landmark success
with this type of
system, probably
still the most
famous demonstration
to date of a deep RL system.
And just to remind those
of you who have not
heard about that, of
course this is our program
to play the game of Go.
And we know that Go was
super hard for computers
to play until AlphaGo came along
because of its enormous search
space and the fact that it's
a very esoteric game, so it's
very difficult to write down
a handcrafted evaluation
function in the way that
chess programs are written.
And I think the reason this
is, is because Go is actually
at the edge of difficulty level
that even humans can cope with,
I would say, whereas chess is
probably just below that limit.
It's slightly less
complex than Go.
And I think Go players
deal with this complexity
by relying heavily on their
intuition and their pattern
matching skills rather than
their explicit calculation
skills, because it's just too
complicated for us to do that.
And that's, of
course, the reason
why it's so difficult to program
these evaluation functions is
even the world's best
players would not
be able to describe to
you precisely how they
are evaluating a position
in terms of a bunch of rules
that could maybe be coded.
So we built these
systems and then
the descendants of AlphaGo,
AlphaGo Zero, and then
AlphaZero and then
more recently MuZero,
and they all basically use
this underlying approach
that I'm going to describe
here, which is really more
the way the AlphaZero and
AlphaGo Zero worked, but you
can think of is the whole way
all of these types of systems
work.
And it's pretty
simple to describe.
So what happens is you
start with a neural network
that's basically random, and
it's trained through hundreds
of thousands and sometimes
millions of games of self-play
to get better at
evaluating a position,
whether it's good or not for
the opponent or for the agent,
and also to predict
what are the right--
the kind of most
likely moves that
should be made in a position
so that it can narrow down
this enormous search space.
And so what happens is
you start with version 1,
let's say, of the
system and it's
going to be pretty bad,
almost random at playing.
You do 100,000 self-play games.
That generates a new
data set, and you
use that data set of games to
train a second neural network,
version 2.
And version 2 tries to
predict which side will
win from a certain
position in those games,
and also what type of move,
try to guess which kind of move
is made by the v.01 system.
So you train up v2, and
then you have a little mini
tournament between v.02
and v.01, 100 games or so.
And there's some
kind of win threshold
where you feel like
v.02 needs to beat v.01
by a certain threshold.
We set that 55% win rate.
And then we regard that
as significantly stronger,
the v.02 than the v.01.
Now, if that happens and v.02
does beat v.01 55% or more
of the time, then you
replace v.01 with v.02
and you do this
whole cycle again.
And you generate
a new set of data,
but this data will be
slightly higher quality,
because now it's v.02
that's generating that data,
and then you train
a version 3, right?
And then you do the little
mini tournament, and you
and you and you go again.
Now, if v.02 does not beat v.01
in that first mini tournament,
you continue to generate
more data with v.01.
So you do another 100,000 games,
and now you've got 200,000
games to train the next
v.02*, one could call it.
And then eventually,
what we find
is that v.02 does
eventually beat v.01.
And in fact, once one
does this around 17 times,
depending on which game
it is, that kind of order,
17 to 20 times, you
go from random play
to better than human world
champion in any two player
game.
And that's the system.
So it's pretty elegant,
and we generalized
it fully to all two-player
games, not just Go,
but any two-player,
perfect information game.
So this will become
relevant in a minute
when we discuss
about how to apply
these techniques to science.
We think of Go really as when
you boil down what AlphaGo is,
Go is this enormous search
space, more positions
than there are atoms
in the universe,
impossible to exhaustively
search by brute force
or any brute force
method to find out
what the right path
through the Go game is.
So what you can think of is
the neural net has learned
this model of the
environment, in this case,
Go positions and likely Go moves
and how good Go positions are.
And that constrains this
enormous search space.
So instead of having to search
this entire search space,
it just searches-- the
Monte Carlo tree search only
needs to search a small,
tiny fraction, this in blue,
of the possibilities.
And then of those, of
course, it picks the best one
that comes out as the best
evaluation, this path in pink,
and that's the path that
is picked once the thinking
time runs out.
And this program is obviously
enormously powerful.
We beat the 18-times
world champion
in a very famous match
in 2016 in Seoul,
which was watched by a couple
hundred million people.
And we won that
match 4-1, and it
was proclaimed to be a
decade before its time.
But those of you who
are familiar with this
will know that
was more important
was actually how AlphaGo
won that match, and the fact
that it came up with
original Go strategies
and Go motifs, including most
famously move 37 in Game 2,
which is here on the right
and encircled in red.
And suffice to say
that this piece was
put on the fifth line, you
can see here the fifth line
from the edge of the board.
And this early in the
game, you should never
play on the fifth line.
We don't really
know why, but that's
the rules of Go
masters will tell you,
you should only play
a move like this
on the fourth line
or the third line,
but definitely not
the fifth line.
Of course, that's all changed
now with AlphaGo doing this.
And obviously, the subsequent
five-plus years now,
all these AlphaGo games
have been studied to death.
And there are many, many
books now written about this,
and it's changed Go theory.
And of course, the
interesting thing about this
was that this move 37 stone,
100 moves later, roughly,
was in exactly the right
position to decide the game,
because the fighting from the
bottom left of this position
spread across the
whole board, and then
the move 37 stone happened
to be in the perfect position
to decide that battle and
then win AlphaGo the game.
So this is very interesting.
So these are clearly
an original strategy,
but we can come
back to, as well,
also in the Q&A about what does
this mean about creativity.
So maybe just to mention
a little bit about
that, I think AI systems
today are very good,
have been very good at for a
long time on interpolation.
So you can think of that as
distinguishing between cats,
pictures of cats and dogs.
And you show the system millions
of cats, millions of dogs,
and it kind of
effectively builds
a sort of prototype of what a
cat and what a dog looks like.
And then so that's kind
of like interpolation,
some kind of average of all
those examples and kind of
creates a template out of that.
This, I would say, is
more like extrapolation.
So these strategies
have never been played
before by human players, right?
So this is not
just interpolation,
some kind of averaging
of what we know is good.
It's true, I would
say, extrapolation.
So I think that is some
form of creativity,
one would have to say.
But on the other hand, I
think there's a further level
to go, which I don't
think AI systems can do,
which one could call true
invention or out of the box
thinking.
And for me that would
be not coming up
with just an original strategy
in Go, but inventing Go, right?
So we don't have
any systems that
can invent Go or invent chess.
And that's a whole
other level, and it's
interesting to
speculate, well, what
would be missing from that?
I think partially we wouldn't
know how to even describe that
to an AI system in a way
that isn't very high level
conceptual, and our current
systems don't really
deal with that very well.
So I think there's one more.
So I think we're
starting to encroach
into the boundaries of
what on may call or think
of as creative, but
there's several more,
I think, levels still to go.
So if you're interested
in this, of course,
there's the AlphaGo film
that's now on YouTube.
And I think if you're
interested in the human story,
if you like, behind
AlphaGo, I highly
recommend this
award-winning documentary.
So then with AlphaZero,
as I was mentioning,
we generalize this next to--
and this is, in general,
the way we tend to--
I think this is a good approach
to engineering sciences.
Usually, you-- at least
what we do at DeepMind
is you try and focus
on performance first.
So you try and get can you
actually master Go at all.
Then once that performance
is reached, you throw out--
you start throwing out
components of the system
to make it more and
more general, less
and less specific to
that particular task,
while still keeping that
performance level up, right?
And then finally, which
is the stage we're getting
to in certain of our systems,
like AlphaZero and a bit
AlphaFold, you can also do
analytics on that system
and try and understand
at a deep level,
open up the black box and
find out how, exactly,
it's working and what is the
knowledge that it's-- how is it
representing the
knowledge that it has.
So AlphaZero, amazingly,
within a few hours,
training from
nothing, would beat
the best programs available
in any of these other games.
And these programs
are already better
than world champion, human
world champion level,
including, you'll see
at the bottom here,
AlphaGo, all the versions
of AlphaGo itself.
So AlphaZero would beat
all versions of AlphaGo.
And that's quite interesting
in itself, right?
So this idea of
generalization can also
give you a little bit
more performance, too,
is the lesson that we
also took from this,
which is quite an
interest-- maybe slightly
counterintuitive.
Of course, because I'm
an ex chess player,
chess was always the
thing I was eventually
going to want to apply this to.
And again, in chess, not only
was it exceptionally strong,
beating Stockfish 8,
which was at the time
the world champion
chess computer
of the traditional
type, but it sort of
invented a new style of chess
where it favored mobility
over materiality.
So almost all chess
programs until AlphaZero
favored material.
So the classic cliche is
that computer grabs a pawn
because if it sees some
material that it can take,
it will try and grab it even
if it then has to hang on
for dear life and defend.
And of course,
computers are very
good at defending
positions because they
don't make any mistakes,
tactical mistakes.
But this was always considered
to be a very ugly way
of playing chess.
So no one would
say, oh, we've seen
this wonderful beautiful
chess computer game.
They were ugly.
They were effective but ugly.
And so this is what
changed about AlphaZero
is not only was it better,
they were beautiful games,
or at least considered to
be beautiful, like this game
here, where AlphaZero is white.
And you can see
what it's done is
it sacrificed a lot
of pieces in exchange
and some pawns in order
to totally imprison
the black pieces and block
all the black pieces in.
So in fact, none
of the Black pieces
can move without
losing something,
even though the black is
winning on material here.
And in chess, that's
called Zugzwang,
that kind of position
where any move you make
makes your position worse.
And this kind of position
was never seen before.
The famous YouTube
chess commentators
called this the
immortal Zugzwang game
because no one had ever seen
a position like this, where
you've got such powerful pieces
like the Queens and the Rooks
and they can't do anything.
So this is pretty incredible.
How is AlphaZero doing this?
Well, my speculation, and
we've also analyzed it
with some of the
ex-world chess champions,
and we opened up the system to
them, like Vladimir Kramnik,
and they helped us
understand that.
And we've written a
paper recently analyzing,
seeing if we can reverse
engineer AlphaZero and find out
what the rules are that it's
built implicitly in AlphaZero.
And it's obviously better
at evaluating positions
than chess engines.
And the reason is
because it doesn't
have to overcome
these inbuilt rules.
So in order-- if you think
about why chess computers don't
sacrifice their
pieces a lot, it's
because they have inbuilt
tables, valuation tables that
tell them Rooks
are worth 5 points,
Knights are worth 3 points.
So in order for it to
sacrifice a Rook for a Knight,
it will have to
work out explicitly
through its brute
force search that it's
going to get the 2 points
back somehow, right?
And if it can't work that
out within its event horizon,
then it won't do it,
whereas AlphaZero doesn't
have those input rules,
so it's much freer
to take into account
the contextual factors
of the current position and
just say in this position,
that Knight is super powerful.
It's on an outpost.
And my Rook's passive, so
I'm just going to swap them.
It doesn't have to overcome
this inbuilt bias, if you like.
It's also better at
balancing different factors
against each other.
So one of the problems
with rule-based systems
is that you have maybe 1,000
rules at this point in the best
chess programs, and not
only are those rules
are they the right rules and
are they expressed correctly,
but also one has to balance
those rules against each other,
which is a super difficult kind
of hand optimization problem.
And also, probably, you'd
want a different balance
in different positions.
And of course, a chess
computer, rules-based computer
is not able to do that, right?
You have to have one
set of balancing rules.
But AlphaZero, again, is free
to perhaps overweight things
dynamically, depending
on the position.
The other cool thing
about these systems
is they do a lot less search
for the strength of the play.
So a human
grandmaster, our models
are incredibly
sophisticated so we only
have to do a very
small amount of search
to come up with a good move.
So maybe a human grandmaster
does maybe a few hundred moves
of search for every decision.
State of the art chess
engines, these brute force
rules-based engines need
to do tens of millions
of searches per
evaluate, per decision.
And AlphaZero is
somewhere in the middle.
It's not quite as efficient
yet as human grandmasters,
but it's orders of
magnitude more efficient
than standard chess programs.
So if you're interested in
reading more about this,
there's obviously
our paper, and also
a whole book written by
the British chess champion
about all the different
styles and the implications
of that for chess that
AlphaZero came up with.
And in fact, you don't
have to just trust
my description of that.
Here's a couple of really nice
quotes from Magnus Carlson,
who's an amazing world
champ, the current world
champion, amazing chess player.
"I have been influenced by my
heroes recently, one of which
is AlphaZero."
And I think he was the
first player really
to integrate these new
ideas into his own play.
And Kasparov said,
"Programs usually reflect
the priorities and prejudices
of the programmers,
but because AlphaZero
learns for itself,
I would say its style reflects
the truth," which is a pretty
cool thing for him to say.
So just wrapping
this up, then, we've
been very fortunate
to make a whole bunch
of big breakthroughs in game
AI, starting with our Atari work
back in 2012, actually,
and published in 2014,
where learning to play directly
from the pixels on the screen
and no other information,
AlphaGo and AlphaZero,
I just mentioned to you.
And then finally, we
tackled the most what's
considered to be the most
complex strategy game video
game, StarCraft II, and reached
a grandmaster level at that,
as well, with AlphaStar.
So that was really the history
of where we've been working on,
on games, because they're
so efficient to develop
these algorithmic ideas,
they're really easy to test.
They're safe
sandboxes, in a way.
Like, it doesn't really
matter if your AI
does something wrong.
It's just a game.
But also, they are
really good metrics
to measure how are
you progressing.
Obviously, the win rate
or the grading, or you
can evaluate the quality
of the move or benchmark
it against the best human
players in the world
in each one of these games.
So the exciting
thing was actually
our shift in the last
few years to start
to use these AI systems to
explore scientific discovery
itself.
And what we looked for is three
criteria for a suitable problem
that maybe we can tackle
with these types of systems.
So first of all, we actually
actively seek out problems
that can be considered as
massive combinatorial search
spaces or state spaces.
And the reason we like
those types of problems
is that means that exhaustive
brute force approaches will not
be tractable here, right?
So we actively seek out
these types of regimes.
And we think we're
particularly suitable--
our techniques are particularly
suitable for these types
of regimes.
Second of all, we look for
a clear objective function
or measure to optimize
against, so that we can hill
climb against it and figure
out if we're making progress
or not.
And then finally, we
look for obviously we
need enough data in which
to learn our models,
and/or potentially the existence
of an accurate and efficient
simulator.
And-- ideally, it's an and--
and in most of the
things that we tackle,
we usually have both.
It's very interesting,
actually, though,
that one of the
things that we've
got very good at over the
years we've been doing this
is that even if you don't
have enough data to learn
your model directly, you may
have enough data in order
to cobble together a simulator.
And then the simulator
can then be run,
and to generate synthetic
data, more synthetic data
to augment your real data.
And you can also
analyze that data
to see if it's from the right
distribution and the quality
of it.
And we've actually found that
even if the simulator data is
of less-- usually, it's not as
good quality as the real data.
As long as there's
some signal in it,
it's actually still
pretty useful.
And we actually used a
little bit of a variation
on this technique for
AlphaFold, so it was actually
an important part
of AlphaFold, which
I'll come back to in a minute.
So those are the three
criteria, if you like.
And it turns out
if you use this,
so you can use this
criteria to look
at what would be
useful commercially,
and we now have hundreds
of products within Google
that use DeepMind technology.
So pretty much
anything, any service
that you use from Google will
have some DeepMind technology
kind of under the hood
there, whether that's
YouTube recommendations to
your battery life saving
on your Android phones.
Or if you speak
to a Google device
and it speaks back to you,
the text to speech systems
are our system powering
that underneath.
And so you can look
into commercial areas
to see what fits these criteria,
and also, interestingly,
scientifically.
And it turns out if you do
that, there are actually
a lot of things that fit very
well with this set of criteria.
And of course, the
number one thing
that we try to do that
ticks all of these boxes
is the protein folding problem.
I'm sure many of you
will know what this is,
but for those that
don't, it's the problem
of going from an
amino acid sequence,
so the genetic sequence that
describes a protein, directly
to its final 3D
structure that it attains
in nature or in the body.
So this is super useful.
Why is it useful?
Because proteins themselves
are essential to life.
All of life's mechanisms
depend on proteins.
And their 3D
structure is thought
to at least partially determine
their function, right?
The 3D structure of
the protein tells you
quite a lot about its function.
And also, if you want to do
things like drug discovery,
you generally want to target
the surface of the protein,
so you need to know
its 3D shape in order
to know what the right target
areas are for you to target
your chemical compound against.
So this is the protein
folding problem.
But the problem is that
determining the structure
experimentally usually
takes years of painstaking
experimental work.
I think the normal
rule of thumb is
that it takes one PhD
student their entire PhD
to do one protein, and
oftentimes it doesn't work out.
And it's very difficult,
painstaking, technical work.
Now famously, Christian
Anfinsen, about 50 years ago,
actually, almost to the day,
during his Nobel lecture
acceptance speech, he--
it's almost a bit like
a Fermat's last theorem
situation, where he
had a throwaway comment
in a way of like, well,
yes the 3D structure
of a protein should
be fully determined
by its amino acid sequence.
So in theory, this
should be possible,
but who knows how
to do it, right?
So this sparked off a whole
50-year grand challenge,
or quest in biology to try and
solve this problem of protein
folding, and going directly
from this amino acid sequence
to the 3D structure.
Now, one of his contemporaries,
Levinthal, at this point
formulated what's known
as Levinthal's paradox.
And the question is, the big
question for protein folding
is can the protein
structure prediction
problem be solved
computationally, right, purely
computationally?
And one of the issues
is Levinthal's paradox,
which is he worked
out back of envelope,
estimated that
there were about 10
to the power 300 possible
shapes a protein could take,
an average size
protein could take.
So clearly, exhaustively
sampling this
is totally out of the question.
And yet obviously, the
paradox part of this
is that in nature
and in our bodies,
these proteins spontaneously
fold, sometimes
in milliseconds.
So obviously, nature somehow
solves this very efficiently,
right, in an energetic sense.
So that points to
the fact that this
may be possible if we could
attack it in the right way.
And for me, this has been
a very long road, actually,
to get into protein folding.
I first came across
the problem in the '90s
as a student in Cambridge.
One of my friends
circle there was
obsessed with this problem,
the protein folding problem,
even back then.
And I remember at any
opportunity in the bars
and playing pool and
in the college bars
that he would talk about this
problem being foundational,
like if we could crack
this problem then
it would open up all sorts
of new avenues for biology.
And that really stuck in my mind
as he described the problem,
and I thought it was
a fascinating problem.
And I also in the
back of my mind
felt it was the type of problem
that AI might one day be
suitable for AI to tackle.
So I kind of filed it
away, because obviously
the AI techniques
back in the '90s
is when I was still
writing computer games
and doing my AI in the
guise of computer games
was not ready to tackle anything
remotely like protein folding,
but it really stuck to me
as a fascinating problem.
And then the second time I
came across it was actually
when I was doing my postdoc
with Tommy here at MIT,
and this game came
out called Foldit.
Some of you might remember.
It came out, I think in
roughly 2008 from Baker Lab,
and it was really, I think,
the best and probably still
the best example of what one
would call a citizen science
game.
So what happened with
this game, Foldit,
is that the Baker Lab turned
the protein folding problem
into a puzzle game, pretty
esoteric but quite fun
puzzle game for of
that persuasion.
And they actually got
lots and lots of gamers
to play this game
and actually choose
to make bends in the
backbone of the protein.
And you get an estimate of the
energy score, right, basically.
And you were trying to
minimize this free energy.
And what was really cool
about that is that--
well, firstly, I was
fascinated by the idea
of the general public
having fun with the game,
but really they
were contributing
to science, which seems
like if we could actually
tap that, that would be
pretty cool for gamers
and for science, I think.
And so I was pretty
fascinated by that idea.
But also, I was quite
intrigued that the best players
of the Foldit game
actually found
some real structures, and
actually apparently some pretty
important ones that were
published in Nature and Nature
Structural Molecular Biology
in the subsequent years.
And so I was thinking as I
was watching this, looking
at this in 2010, roughly
that kind of time,
well, what's happened there?
How is this possible?
And when you look into the kind
of moves that the players made,
they were making local moves
that were actually increasing
the energy, the free
energy for the moment,
because overall they
realized later on they
might be able to solve that--
actually globally, that
there would be lower energy.
And this is the reason why
greedy energy minimization
methods don't work,
because they just
get stuck into local maxima.
So they're obviously able to
somehow use their intuition,
I guess the pattern
matching of these gamers.
They weren't biologists,
they were just gamers.
But some of them are really
good at pattern matching,
and they presumably were
using that to find their way,
their intuition, if you like, to
find their way to a good fold.
So then later on-- so
that was filed away, too.
And then later on, when we beat
Lee Sedol in the Seoul match
and I thought back to in
the process of that what
were we doing,
really, with AlphaGo
is we mimicked the intuition
of these Go masters, right?
And believe me, if you talked
to these Go masters, that's
all they've ever
done in their lives.
I play Go from the age of
two or three years old,
go to Go school--
they don't go to
a normal school.
That's-- you cannot get a
more highly trained mind
for a particular task
than a Go master.
I literally-- I think
it's kind of impossible.
So if we were able to mimic
their intuition in Go,
then why would it
not be possible to do
something analogous
in this protein space?
So that gave me the feeling
that this was definitely
a crackable problem
with our techniques.
So we actually started
the AlphaFold project
almost the day after we
got back off the plane
from Seoul with AlphaGo.
And we actually found
a bit of recording
somewhere where I was talking to
Dave Silver, who is the project
leader now for Go
out in Seoul, and I
think we must have just won
the third match or something.
And we were literally
discussing this
like I think now is the
time to push forward
on the protein folding project.
So that's what we did.
Another really important
part of the story
was the existence
of this competition
called CASP, Critical
Assessment of protein Structure
Prediction.
And it's an amazing competition.
It's considered to be like the
Olympics for protein folding,
and it runs every two years.
And it's run by this amazing
group of organizers who've
been running it since 1994.
So they've diligently kept this
going for close to 30 years
now.
And what they do is
that throughout a year,
experimental departments
produce new crystals
and experimental determined
structures of proteins, right?
But over a kind of three
month period, what they do
is they hold back
publishing those results
and they instead submit their
newly freshly found structures
into this competition.
But it's a blind
assessment, so the people,
the computational teams that
compete in this competition
don't know the structure.
Nobody, in fact,
knows the structure
other than the group, the
experimental group that
had just found it.
And then you get--
it's quite exciting.
You get a sequence
emailed to you
and you have one week to
get back with your best
guess of the structure.
And it's pretty fun, and
you do it over a summer.
And then at the end of
all that, the organizers,
they release the real
structures and they
measure how close were
your predictor structures
of all the different teams
to the experimentally
determined ground truth.
And so I want to
give a big shout out
to John Moult, who is
the founder of this
and the other CASP
organizers, who
work so hard over
many, many years
to maintain this competition.
And I actually think it's a
pretty good model for helping
science to progress, and
maybe should be thought
about in other domains, too.
So historically, then, what
have been happening at CASP?
Well, it turns out when
you look back on it
that there'd been very
little progress at CASP
for over a decade.
So here on this graph, I'm
showing you the winning--
the median accuracy
for the winning team
at each subsequent
CASP competition,
starting in 2006 with CASP 7
and going to 2016 with CASP 12.
And on the y-axis, you can see
it's a measure of the accuracy
that the winning team
got, and it's called GDT.
I won't go into details
of how it's calculated,
but you can think about,
roughly speaking, it's
the percentage of residues
that you have accurately
put in the right position
within a certain tolerance,
certain distance
tolerance, right?
So obviously, you're trying to
get close to 100% if you can.
And you can see here
that basically there'd
been almost no
progress, and they
were stuck around this
40% level that's basically
a kind of useless structure.
So this was sort of stagnated.
And then we came
along in 2018, which
is the first one we
entered after working
on AlphaFold for a couple
of years with AlphaFold 1,
and we made this huge leap.
And I think it kind of
revolutionized the field.
So we were the first-- it
was the first time really
that cutting edge machine
learning had been applied
at scale as the core
component of a solution
to the protein folding problem.
And AlphaFold 1 won
the competition.
But not only did it win,
it won by almost 50%
above the next best team.
And you can see,
so that would have
meant that the teams were still
tracking along the gray bars
if it wasn't for
this new advance.
And then of course, that's
not where we wanted to stop.
We wanted to actually
solve the problem.
And we had-- in
2020, we actually
re-architected the whole
system for the 2020 competition
to reach atomic accuracy.
And that was AlphaFold 2.
So that was, again, another even
bigger leap above AlphaFold 1.
So these were the results
in terms of accuracy.
So AlphaFold 2 sort of
achieved this atomic accuracy
at CASP 14.
And we were told
by the organizers
back in 2016-17 that the magic
threshold that they considered
to be the threshold that
needed to be crossed
was less than 1 Angstrom error.
That was the kind of
critical threshold
for it to be competitive
with experimental methods,
and therefore
useful in practice.
So that's what we were
always aiming for,
so less than 1 angstrom, so
atomic accuracy, basically
the width of a carbon atom.
And AlphaFold 2
crossed that line
and actually achieve
a 0.96 Angstrom
error in the CASP 14 competition
for the first time ever.
And you can see this was still
actually three times more
accurate than the
next best systems
from some commercial ones like
from Tencent, but also the best
labs that work in this area,
Baker Labs, Zhang Lab, and so
on, which were still around the
3 Angstrom error in CASP 14,
even though they'd already
incorporated the AlphaFold 1
advances that obviously we'd
published after CASP 13.
So this led to the
organizers and John Moult
and the organizers declaring
the structure prediction
problem, protein folding
essentially solved.
And here's some examples of
the outputs of AlphaFold.
Many of you will have
seen this by now,
but this was actually
incredibly wonderful
for us to see this
when we got given back
the results from CASP 14.
And you can see how good
our predictions are,
the ones in blue, and the
ground truth is in green.
And they're overlaid
over each other,
and you can see they're
highly overlapping,
including on the left hand side,
this is a protein from SARS
that even the side chain, so
these little thin stalks which
are the side chains, not on
the backbone of the protein,
are accurately predicted, too.
And this is the architecture
for AlphaFold 2.
So there's a whole
bunch of innovations
that were required here.
I haven't got time to
go into all of them,
but I'll give you the
kind of key takeaways.
If you're interested
in the details there,
you can check out
our Nature paper
that has about 60 pages of
supplemental information.
So it's maybe just a measure
of how complex this system was.
And it was by far the most
complicated system that we
have ever built at DeepMind.
And we built some pretty
complicated systems,
but this is, I would say,
the most complex one ever.
There were actually 32
component algorithms
that went into AlphaFold, as I
mentioned, the 60 pages of SI.
And there was no
real silver bullet
in the end that solved
protein folding.
It actually needed a whole host
of insights and innovations,
and then those innovations
had to be carefully integrated
together.
But the key takeaways were, and
the key advances of AlphaFold 2
compared to AlphaFold
1 was that, firstly, it
was an end to end system with
a kind of iterative recycling
stage that actually builds
the structure piece by piece
and builds that out.
And that allowed
us to go directly
from the amino acid sequence
directly to the 3D structure.
With AlphaFold 1, there
was an intermediate step,
which is that we went from
the amino acid sequence
to what's called a distogram,
so a pairwise distogram of all
the residues to
all the residues.
And then there was a
kind of Newton method
to optimize that, a numerical
method that actually
took the longest part of it.
It took like one
week per protein.
And both those two systems had
to be optimized separately.
And those of you who
work on machine learning
will know, be
familiar with the idea
that the more end to
end you can make things,
generally the better it is.
The kind of optimization that
you do seems to flow better.
And that was definitely
the case here
when we were able to optimize
directly for the 3D structure.
We also used an attention-based
neural network rather than
convolutional neural network.
And that was key
because we were using
a convolutional neural
network for AlphaFold 1.
And of course, if
you think about it,
that's the wrong
type of bias, right?
Like obviously, pixels on
an image, if they're nearby,
they're pretty correlated
in their properties.
But actually, in
fact, that's not
true at all, necessarily,
of amino acids that
are near each other in
the sequence, right?
Obviously, it completely
depends on how the backbone
is going to bend round.
So this attention-based
neural network
would infer the implicit
graph structure.
And then finally, we
were able to build in--
and this was critical--
evolutionary and physical
constraints into the
model architecture
without impacting the training
and the learning, right?
So that was pretty difficult
to build in these constraints
without hurting the learning.
But in the end, that turned
out to be totally essential.
So it was a kind of
huge research effort,
took over five years, at
its peak, about 20 people,
highly multidisciplinary team.
So we have lots of
biologists and chemists
and physicists on
the team, as well as
obviously machine
learning and engineering.
And the other thing to
note is if the output
of a particular applied system
is in itself really valuable
like we thought this
would be for biologists,
then one, maybe you should
relax the constraint
of being general.
So normally, with all our
machine learning research,
we try and be as
general as possible.
But here, we wanted to just
solve the problem by any means.
So we used all of our
general purpose knowledge
and general purpose
algorithms, but then
we actually built in quite
a lot of domain knowledge
in this case, like the
evolutionary physical
constraints, because
we just wanted
to solve the problem here.
In terms of speed and
scale, actually, the system
turns out to be incredibly
fast, especially inference.
So it takes about two weeks
on 8 GPUs, roughly 150 GPUs
to train, so actually a fairly
modest amount of compute
by today's standards.
And the inference
is super fast, so
order of minutes for an average
protein on a single GPU.
So we were thinking
about how to give
broad access to the biology
community using the system.
And normally what you
do with these systems
as you put them on
a server, and then
people submit their
amino acid sequences
and you give them back
a structure, right?
But actually, we
thought we could
do a lot better than that
here and just fold everything
for everyone immediately.
And we wanted-- so we thought,
OK, what should we do?
Because it's fast enough, let's
start with the human proteome.
So that's what we did, and
we actually folded this
over Christmas, I guess, 2020.
So we had this idea straight
off the competition,
lots of computers are
sitting idle over Christmas,
so we just set them going
on the human proteome
and then came back in the
new year and it was done,
which is something I
love about computers.
While you have your
Christmas lunch,
they can be doing
useful work for you.
And so we got all
the predictions.
Actually, we ran this
twice to make sure,
and we got all the predictions
for all of the proteins
in the human proteome,
which is the equivalent
of the human genome, right?
So the human genome
codes for the genes,
which code for the proteins.
And there's about
20,000 proteins
in the human body
expressed by our genome.
So we followed them all.
And just so to put
that in perspective,
experimentally,
after 40, 50 years
of painstaking experimental
work by the entire biology
community, we have
determined about 17%
of the human proteome.
So overnight, we doubled that
to 36% with very high accuracy.
And by very high accuracy, we
mean sub-angstrom accuracy,
so equivalent to
experimental quality.
And then furthermore, 58% we
determined at high accuracy.
And high accuracy means that the
backbone can be trusted, right?
Maybe not the side
chains, but the backbone,
the general overall
structure is probably good.
And that can still
be useful, maybe not
for certain types of things,
not for drug discovery,
for example, but it
can still be useful
for fundamental research.
And then one
interesting thing is
which we've had a lot
more data on since we've
released all this last summer
is what about the other 42%?
What's going on there?
And actually, we suspected
that most of those
were not errors or
deficiencies in the system,
but were actually indicating
something different,
which is that those proteins
were unstructured in isolation.
So there's a lot of proteins
in the body that actually don't
have a structure until they
interact with whatever they're
supposed to interact with,
and they're kind of floppy
before that.
And actually, when
we looked into this,
it was very high correlation
between the known areas
of intrinsic disorder and
where AlphaFold was not good
and it knew it was not good.
So this, taken together, is
the most complete and accurate
picture ever of
the human proteome.
And we knew we wanted
biologists to use this,
some biologists who maybe
would have no interest in how
AlphaFold worked or not have the
expertise to worry about that,
but we wanted them to
trust the downstream data
and to use it in their work.
So we knew that it would be
really important to create
a very simple confidence
measure that biologists could
look at and understand really
simply without understanding
anything about the underlying
architectural details.
And this is always
something we would
like to have in general
with our machine learning
models, a kind of
measure of uncertainty
and how uncertain the system
is about its own outputs.
But in this case, we
thought it was critical.
And actually, we
developed a system that--
we actually made a
slight tweak to AlphaFold
that also extracted
its own confidence
metric about how confident
it was about each residue
position.
And greater than 90 basically
means that you can rely on it,
it's kind of experimental
level, and greater than 70
is this high accuracy
regime, and lower than 50
may indicate disorder.
So we founded another 20
model organisms, or the most
important ones for research,
the mouse, the fruit fly,
zebrafish, and then also some
major diseases, tuberculosis,
and then some big plants
like rice and wheat.
And we're starting to cover more
and more of the biology space.
So we also did,
in the first half
of last year created a database
with EMBL-EBI, the European
Bioinformatics Institute,
based in Cambridge.
They build already a lot of the
big databases, like Uniprot,
and we went to them and
collaborated with them
to build the AlphaFold
Protein Structure
Database to host all
of these structures
in 3D and all the
other tools and link
in to all of the other
genetics tools and other tools
that biologists use
every day, so it just
becomes part of their
everyday workflow.
And we did a big first release
with 330,000 total structures
for these 20 model organisms
plus the human proteome,
and we put it out there for
free and unrestricted access
for any use,
commercial, academic,
freely to use it to maximize
the scientific impact
and benefit to humanity.
We now have more than a million
predictions in the database.
We've done 440,000
annotated ones
from what's called Swiss-Prot.
We've also indexed heavily early
on neglected tropical diseases,
because they're often
very understudied.
Big pharma doesn't do
much research on them
because there isn't
much money in it,
but it affects millions of
people around the world,
and it's terrible for their
quality of life and so on.
So we actually work with
the WHO to prioritize--
this is what we're
doing in-house--
prioritize these tropical
diseases like Chagas disease,
leishmaniasis, that
affect millions
of people around the world
and are understudied.
So that means that
the nonprofits can now
start with drug design
because they have the protein
structures.
And we've seen it already within
barely like nine months now,
huge amount being done by
the community with AlphaFold
for modeling very
complex biology that
was not modelable before.
So this on the left
here is an image
of the nuclear pore complex.
This is what allows
things in and out
of your nucleus of
your cell, and it's
one of the biggest
proteins in the body.
It's really huge.
There's using AlphaFold as
a state of the art protein
disorder predictor,
so many people are now
using it to predict disorder.
Another project with
the WHO is to-- they
identify the top
30 pathogens that
might cause a future pandemic,
and they wanted all the protein
structures for those, so
we've given that to WHO.
And actually, it's helped
experiment us a lot
to solve their own protein
structures because sometimes
they have low resolution
experimental data,
and if they can also use
as another source of input
AlphaFold's prediction,
they can use
that to combine that to
resolve a very high resolution
image of actually their protein.
And there's actually
now hundreds
of already other papers
and applications that
have been using AlphaFold,
both within industry and also
academia.
And the impact, be really big.
It got listed very nicely in
the Breakthrough of the Year
by Science and also Method
of the Year from Nature.
And the database
has been used now
by over 350,000 researchers.
And we think there are only
about 400,000 biologists
in the world, so we think
that pretty much everyone
has looked at the database
and is using the database.
And so it's super gratifying
for us to see that.
So now, where are we going next?
There's actually over 100
million proteins or actually
nearly 200 million
proteins known to science.
There's all these expeditions
that go to the Indian Ocean
or somewhere like that and they
dip a bucket into the water
and you pull it out, and if
you sequence what you get
you actually get whole
loads of new proteins
and you stick them in
the protein databases,
but no one knows the structures
of any of these things, right?
So now potentially, we could be
in a regime for the first time
ever where proteomics can
keep up with genomics, right?
So you can have as many
proteins to know about,
protein structures
as abundant as we
know about genetic material.
So that's a really
interesting thing,
what then one might
do a met level
about looking at this
enormous data set,
and I'm very excited to see
what protein biologists end up
doing with that.
Yeah, so then function would
be the next thing to look at.
So thanks.
I wanted to say thanks to
everybody, amazing teams who
made AlphaFold possible.
There's the methods team,
everybody listed on the left
there, and John Jumper
leading the technical part
of that team and the
human proteome side
and with Kathryn
leading that project.
And I also want to thank,
obviously, our wider
colleagues at DeepMind.
Like, almost everybody
at DeepMind in some way
contributed to this, and also
Alphabet, the collaborators
at EMBL-EBI, CASP community,
and also the PDB, of course,
in the experimental
biology community who
created those first 150,000
structures that then we
were able to learn from.
And I just wanted to mention
about the augmentation part.
So it turns out
one of the things
we had to do with AlphaFold
was do self-distillation,
we're calling it
self-distillation,
where we actually
train on 150,000.
We output some predictions
of some other proteins.
And then we did a filter
on the high quality ones,
or at least the ones AlphaFold
thought were higher quality,
and we put that back
in the training set.
And actually, that helped a lot.
And we needed about 250,000
to 300,000 synthetic,
in this case, predictions
in the training set.
It was very helpful and
quite important to get
the last few percentages
out of AlphaFold.
So I'm just going to
end, then, by talking
a little bit, a couple
of slides on the future.
So now we're working on many
other related projects, protein
complexes, disorder proteins,
and point mutations,
mostly dynamics of
proteins you can think
of, and also protein design.
So there's a whole
area, I think,
that has been unlocked
with AlphaFold,
and we're going to
push further on.
And others are pushing
further on all these topics.
And there's just an
observation on biology,
really, which is that
the more I worked on this
and spent the last
five years looking
at the exquisite biological
system that goes on
in our bodies, it's kind of
amazing to think that it can
even work given its complexity.
And I think that one way
to understand biology
is at its fundamental level,
it's an information processing
system.
I really believe that's
the kind of fundamental way
to look at it.
But of course, life is
a very complex process
and it's an emergent process.
And I think because
of that, it's
pretty difficult to
describe mathematically
in a kind of clean way.
Like, if you think about trying
to describe a whole cell,
is there ever going to be
a Newton's laws of motion
for a cell?
I don't think so.
I think it's too complicated
and it's too emergent.
So in a way, it could be
the perfect regime for AI
to operate in.
And I think as
maths is to physics,
maths is like the
perfect description
language for physics,
I think AI could
be the perfect description
language for biology.
And I hope that AlphaFold will
be not just useful in itself,
but also kind of
proof of concept
of maybe a heralding of
a new dawn of what I call
and others call digital biology.
And the dream would one day be
maybe to create a virtual cell
that one could make
useful predictions in,
in silico, right?
Obviously, we're
very far from that,
but AlphaFold is maybe
the first tentative step.
And then, of course, I haven't
got time to talk about all
of these things, but we've
had a really amazing year
of applying these
types of AI techniques
to quantum chemistry,
pure mathematics proving
some pretty major conjectures,
fusion, controlling the plasma
in a fusion m and genomics.
And if it sounds a little bit
science fiction, this list,
these are all real papers.
You can go and have
a look at them.
And this was always
the flourishing
that I had imagined
when we started
DeepMind was that
if we crack this
in the right way, this kind
of diet, this kind of slide
should be possible, even though
it seems like perhaps science
fiction.
So I'll just end then
by saying in my view,
AI used properly could be the
ultimate general purpose tool
to help scientists see
further, much like the Hubble
telescope was for
cosmologists to see further
into the universe.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]